[Music]
you're gonna love this Papa
you're gonna love this I'll tell you why
if I were to
no you know what
will that Brendan tell you this is
Brendan talking about Dave Chappelle
you know Mega star comedian Dave
Chappelle I've heard about him have you
yeah
he was the black guy from Robin Hood Men
in Tights yeah some people have said
he's pretty he's like he's got a pretty
good career ahead of him have you seen
the movie Half Baked
cover of that it was my first time
headlining at the comedy stars in the
bedroom I was all excited like I wonder
where they'd asked me to do this like
six years ago turns out there's like six
people in the crowd and it was the the
opening game of the World Series with
the Dodgers so there's nobody there so I
feel like a piece of [ __ ] but then Dave
Chappelle walks in he's in the Green
Room he's like hey you're running the
show I'm like yeah the headliner he's
like you mind if I do a set man is that
cool with you I'm like sure you do
whatever whatever you want right so
we're in the green room talking and
there's like I'm feeling so sad because
only seven people in there and me and
him are vibing like this is their Vibe
he was broke they're vibing vibing yeah
they shared a moment two legends two
legends you know what this this is like
there was like Richard Pryor like
shaking Carlin's hand black and white
double smoking a cigarette like Legends
meeting you know they met all the time
yeah but this is different we're in
Carson together yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but imagine bro like bro imagine
George Carlton bro
he's vibing bro they're vibing very
often we're in the same [ __ ] George
Carlton and Richard pryder were [ __ ]
just vibing they would go see each other
together and then Sam Kinnaman came in
yeah Sam kinnamon came in Papa because
I'm kiddingman came in and he started
screaming that's what this felt like cam
cinnamon Kim cinnamon came in Papa
let's see what happens
so [ __ ] dope man Dave Chappelle I'm
sorry I know I puzzle and I apologize
were you wearing that hat when you met
him I was about to say you're about to
sing about how happy you are Pharrell
looks like a member of the Royal
Canadian Mounted Police
right with the flannels and the [ __ ]
hat
[ __ ] it does looks like the Hat the
Amish would take out to the club on
rumspringer if the Royal Canadian
Mounted Police had a plain clothes
division
he's about to [ __ ] he said he's about
to save a woman that's tied to a train
track from Snidely Whiplash oh [ __ ]
decisions
Johnny Depp from Secret Window looking
[ __ ] yeah Sir Johnny Depp in
real life what are you doing man
God he's so terrible sorry and then he's
vaping and I go oh it just ruined our
relationship he probably hates me to
this day if he even remembers me he
doesn't he's vape and I go oh you know
those are worse for you than cigarettes
imagine you mean somebody who's going to
go down in history as one of the
greatest comedians of all time right
imagine you meet him
and instead of like just being like bro
so lucky I got like you're in the same
you're both Comics if you're the same
thing you'll pick his brain and you you
help you get like a you hope you get
like a hey man you're good kid good luck
you know one of those things like to
throw the jersey at your thing like and
then instead you go
Vape you're bad for your
did not go once you're smoking you
should shut up unless there unless you
want unless you're witnessing the famous
person do something that to you is just
so morally Republican yeah that you have
to speak up but everything else you
should just be able to go oh I can shut
up about this
oh you know those are worse for you than
cigarettes
by the way even though it was like oh
this is the Purgatory this is the
Purgatory when you become one of these
discrete quote unquote disgrace
comedians your Purgatory the way you're
let back in is you have to do a show
with Brendan Schaub that's the only way
you are gonna have to carry him listen
I'm if you're a Delia you're a Kalin and
these people when you get disgraced out
there you gotta do a show with Brendan
sharp you have to that's your opinion
this show is basically like Impact
Wrestling like when you [ __ ] up enough
you got to go to impact and just be
reliable for a year yeah for anybody
will [ __ ] with you again and Bobby fish
over here is [ __ ] being like yeah I
need to get the [ __ ] out of here I need
to get the [ __ ] out of here I need to
get the [ __ ] out of here have you heard
all his promos like dead silence it's so
funny I think aw botches might have some
of them too what the [ __ ] you just said
you saw that promo Joe thing with the
Tumbleweeds yes
okay sorry oh you know those are worse
for you than cigarettes
he goes what the [ __ ] you just said
you know the Vapes actually works for
you than cigarettes
he had a chance
he say everything twice say everything
twice he actually God gave him a chance
to redeem himself so let's say I do it
and I realized I [ __ ] up hey Dave
those are worse for you in the
cigarettes and you go what the [ __ ] you
say huh
I'm just [ __ ] around man who gives a
[ __ ] you want a cigarette
you could have saved yourself still but
instead what you did because you're a
buffoon is you double down because
you're an idiot
she goes who told you that like oh it's
just what to say he's like who says that
I'm like oh [ __ ] dude wow he's like my
doctor says better that's why he told me
to start vaping like but I don't think
it is
triple
triple's his best triples is the safest
safest
tell the kid about the Vape because if
that's not true no it's none of it's
true
oh my God
and he was like all right man and they
just walked off never talked to him
again
all you had to do was say nothing to be
fair you'd never want to talk to him
again yeah I don't think I don't think
that you would have been opening for him
in his next Netflix special you know
he's a dumb guy and I know I know we say
that a lot but like he really is he's a
dumb kid he's a dumb kid